Kylie Jenner stepped out and slayed the
red carpet with her big sis Kim
Kardashian at the Vanity Fair Oscar
party but inside was joined by her ex
Travis Scott Edie had learned that Kylie
and Travis hung out with her family at
the party and hipping quotes spending
more and more time together
Kylie even uploaded this video to her
Instagram story with Travis Kourtney and
Khloe but we hear the pair isn't putting
pressure on officially being back
together organic after breaking things
off in October Stormies parents are
quote better than ever our source adds
Kylie and Travis truly enjoy one another
and are in love but it can often be hard
navigating their lives at such a young
age earlier this month they celebrated
stormy second birthday with an
over-the-top party of course themed
stormy world a play on her dad Travis
Scott's Astroworld
the 22 year old make a mogul went with
the same theme last year but this year's
party tagline reminded guests that two
is better than one two is better than
one
Travis was even rocking a hoodie with
stormy face all over the back Kylie
clearly takes a role as mama super
seriously and she recently told him
during their makeup tutorial that she
sees herself having a few more kiddos I
see myself for sure having four kids I
just don't know when I'd on the timeline
to this
don't know if I'm gonna have orchids
tomorrow from the 430 like seven years
[Music]